I want to take up in September the 6th, 1924 and this is about the crucifixion of the church.
As I was in my usual state, Louisa said, "I found myself outside of myself and to my surprise,
I found a woman cast to the ground in the middle of the street. She was all full of wounds,
her members all dislocated, not one bone who's in its place." The woman, though in such a
sorry state, has to seem to be a true portrait of pain, was beautiful, noble and majestic.
But at the same time, it aroused pity to see her abandoned by all,
exposed to anyone who might want to harm her. So moved to compassion, I looked around to see if
there was anyone who would help me to lift her from the ground and take her to a safe place.
Now what he's looking at is an image of the church crucified and torn apart, abandoned by all,
so you can see that the future for the church is that the church has to go through the passion,
death and resurrection of Jesus. And just as Jesus was abandoned by all,
he was betrayed by many, he was tortured and his bones were dislocated. This is what you're
seeing in this image for the church and that's what's ahead for us. So she looked around to see
what anyone helped her and all marveled, she said, "A young man appeared at my side who seemed to be
Jesus and together we lifted her from the ground." Now you see the importance of the victim's soul
and the one whom Jesus calls to a special mission, that between her and Jesus they can actually lift
the church. I've always said that in the 20th century it was Padre Pio and Louisa where the
main people that the Lord used to keep the church going and keep it from disintegrating all together.
When you go back to the 12th century, I might be wrong, it might be the 11th century, St Francis of
Assisi was asked to put his shoulder to the church and helped to raise the church at a time of great
difficulty as well. So Louisa said, "We lifted her from the ground but at every movement she suffered
harrowing pains just as Louisa describes Jesus on the cross due to the dislocation of her bones."
So little by little we carried her into a palace. I love that you go from this total abandonment
into a palace. So you go from death to resurrection and we put her upon a bed and together with Jesus
who seemed to love this woman so much as to want to give his own life to save her and restore her
health, we took the dislocated members of our hands in our hands to put them back in place. Now we're
going to see as we go on that as we do our acts in the divine will we are actually helping to
put those bones back in position. We're helping to rebuild the church. At the touch of Jesus the
bones would take their place and that woman was transformed into a beautiful and graceful child.
I think that's very interesting. I want to give you Matthew 19, 14, a beautiful graceful child.
Louisa was surprised but then Jesus said to her, "My daughter, this woman is the image of my church.
She's always noble. She's always full of majesty and always holy because her origin
comes from the son of the celestial father." Now we've already been told in all the volumes
up to here that the origin of either an act or a situation tells you the importance of it. If the
origin of an act is divine, it's a divine act. If the origin is human, it's a human act. The origin
of the church is that she comes from the son of the heavenly father and therefore she's holy
in herself. Now the church has always taught us that the church is holy even though many of her
members are not holy. So her origin comes from the son of the celestial father. What to what a
sorrowful state have the members incorporated into her have reduced her. So here you have the
difference between individuals who are part of the church and this mystery of the bride of Christ
itself. Now all the saints and all the popes down the centuries have distinguished those two realities
as well. Not content with living as holy as she is, they, that's the members, have brought her into
the middle of the street, that is exposing her to the world and all the devastation of the world,
exposing her to the cold to mockeries and to blows. So if the members of the church
are behaving in the opposite of the way that they should as members of the body of Christ,
then it's the same as dragging Jesus out into the crowd to have him mocked and scourged and crucified.
And her very children, like dislocated members, living in the middle of the street, that means
living as Greg would say outside the window, living in the world and therefore by the world's
principles, living in the middle of the street have given themselves to all sorts of vices.
And the first one mentioned is the love of interest. Now I think we should put the economy
there because the church has become very worldly today, very much involved in the things of the
world and the economy or money has just simply taken over. And we know you can't serve God and
money, as Jesus said. The love of interest, which is predominant in them, makes them blind
and they commit the ugliest evils, living near her to wound her and to say to her continuously,
let her be crucified, let her be crucified. Now this was given a century ago. And so the
crucifixion of the church began a century ago. I think it's well on now.
So I'll give you Luke 22, 21 for that when they cried for Jesus to be crucified. What a sorrowful
state my church is in. Those ministers who should defend her are her most cruel executioners.
Now this is 1924. The infiltration of communism is at work very strongly in the church.
And it was the communists who said that the structure of the church was so perfect
that it had to be destroyed from within. It's her own ministers that have to destroy her.
Now if we were looking at that, not knowing what happened in the infiltration of the church,
you'd be very disturbed. But in actual fact, as you know, the communists put atheists into
seminaries, paid them hugely to pass all their exams and be better than everybody else. And so
atheists became priests. And since atheists in the priesthood have no grace and no vocation,
then they brought homosexuality into the priesthood. And it is taken on like a COVID-19.
What a sorrowful state my church is in. Those ministers who should defend her are the most
cruel executioners. But in order for her to be reborn. So after the death comes resurrection,
it's necessary to destroy these members. Well, you see, if you know who they are,
I mean, if an atheist is a bishop and he's been an atheist all the time,
well, then he's never going to be somebody the Lord can actually use. They have to be
eliminated. So I want to give you, first of all, John 15, two, any branch that doesn't bear fruit
will be cut off from the vine. And then I want to give you Revelation 11, 18, it's the second half
of the verse. So you put a little B on it, I will destroy the destroyers of the earth is what it says.
So you have to notice that we're being told that when chastisement comes,
the chastisement can be selective. That's very interesting. So in order for the church to be
reborn, it's necessary that these destructive members be removed. They must be cut off from the
vine and to incorporate into her innocent members with no self interest on a general level what's
being referred to here is what are called career prelates priests who in the priesthood want a
career and they want to get to the top and they want influence and they want power and they want
money and so on. So they have no interest in the real thing. So the Lord wants to incorporate
innocent members so that as they will live like her, now we were told that she was holy
because her origin was holy and she was noble and full of majesty and she has this great mission
to save the world in and through Christ. So the Lord needs innocent people in their innocent means
without sin. It doesn't mean ignorant. So that she may return and become a beautiful and graceful
child. Now that's Matthew 18 3. Jesus told the apostles, some of whom were older than himself,
that they would have to change radically and become like little children. That means that you have
innocence, that you have humility, that you have openness and that you are willing to learn.
These characteristics you find in children and of course you are without guile.
The church may return to be a beautiful and graceful child as I constituted her
without malice. That's the guile and malice of course is sin in a very evil sense. It's not
just a simple fall. That she would be more than a simple child in order to grow strong and holy.
Here is the necessity is what my book says. We would say here's the reason why the enemies
wage battle. In other words this is the reason why the Lord has to allow the church to be attacked.
Some things need it weeding out. Some things need it to be dealt with. I mean in these
lockdown days some people have made an attack on their houses,
creative problems for the people collecting bins, the bins or so forth. So as soon as you
make an attack on your house like that things have to go. And so you make a selection as to what
goes and what stays. Well a persecution does the same thing. It clears things out so that the
infected members may be purged to see that it is selective and why we've been told and that those
who are in the book of Revelation, that those who are marked with the mark of Christ that they will
be preserved during the tribulation those who are living in the divine will that you are marked
and you are preserved. So then Jesus says to Louisa you must pray and suffer that everything
may be for my glory and then he left that particular moment of encounter. So that's kind of an introduction
to the rest that we're going to look at now. The messages this evening are very rich and very
profound and if you want to make a talk on how to live in the divine will you're just going to get
it. It's just absolutely fantastic one, two, three, four, five, six. Anyway the first thing we learn
in September the 11th 1924 are the terrible effects of the opposition of the soul to the divine will.
It's difficult for us poor little creatures on the earth to realize the enormity of what
we've entered into and to realize the enormity of an act or a resistance to an act.
So Louisa said I was feeling disturbed and you know from volumes one to four he doesn't allow
disturbance. You can have loads of disturbance on the outside of you there's a crisis in the country
there's a crisis in the whole world but you're not supposed to have that disturbance inside of you
inside of you he wants complete cam and total trust that you let him reign.
So Louisa said I was feeling very disturbed and I prayed Jesus to have compassion on me and to take
himself all the care of my poor soul. Now you won't believe it we're on volume 17
and she's back to her usual that she doesn't want the priest to come. This is the thorn in her side
she has not let this go and when I see Louisa still having problems in volume 17 with something
that she was given the answer to in volume one maybe not volume one volume two then I say to myself
have compassion on yourself and have compassion on everybody else because there are some things
we actually find extremely difficult to let go and what that thing is in each person's life
will be different to others. For some people letting go their own opinion can be the worst thing of all.
So here's Louisa and it's the priest coming to get her out of her ecstatic state.
So she said oh please take everyone away from me I don't mind as long as you alone remain
with me you alone are enough from me. Now that was echoed by St. Teresa of Avila when she said
God alone sufficed and we have to learn in the divine will that God alone actually can suffice
for the soul. Now the whole country's down in lockdown where people in the divine will should
be having a wonderful time because we're all on retreat. We all have God all to ourselves.
I think it's the most wonderful time of grace for us but there are others and they're having
terrible crises because they can't cope because they haven't got this wonderful relationship with
God. So here's Louisa saying you can take everybody I only need you and I ask for nothing but you alone.
Now while I was saying this and other things she said my Jesus took my arm and of course she
thought instantly that he was going to do the job that the priest does. As if he himself wanted
to free me and therefore to do for me the office of my confessor oh I'm happy I felt in seeing Jesus
do this and I thought to myself finally the hardest of my sacrifices is over. No way.
If something is costing you this much it's a huge divine currency and therefore it's actually
necessary as part of your gift God. But it's more than that for Louisa because if the priests were
taken away this revelation that God was making for the entire church would not have been accepted
by the church. It would just simply be brushed aside it's just one human being's opinion and so
the priests had to be forced to be involved in the thing the whole time day in day out so that
they had enough witness themselves. Enough witness to make a saint out of Hannibal de Francea.
So finally she said the hardest of my sacrifices is over but vain and fleeting was my happiness
as the Lord took my arm at that very instant he escaped and I was left in my usual state without
being able to come round. How I cried and I prayed that he would have compassion on me okay now
the challenge here is when we have I've often said to you before that a cross is something that
you would give to anybody anytime under any conditions you just want to get rid of it. And Louisa doesn't
see that this and the privation are her two big crosses she can't see it and many people can't see
their cross either. And the other thing they can't see even though the Lord has given Louisa quite
a bit of instruction as to how to deal with the privation she still can't see that she should trust
God beyond reason. Our problem is that our little head gets in the way and we're prepared to trust
him within reason. What to trust him beyond reason is a bit difficult for us but you will be
totally successful in life and you will make enormous strides in the divine will if you trust
him beyond reason it's that simple. So Louisa says after a few hours Jesus came back and seeing me
crying and all in bittered he said my daughter do not cry don't you want to trust your Jesus?
You see the issue is very very often just simply that let God be God but we have this awful
thing in us that we want to be in control that we have this need as as adult human beings
to be in control and to hand over the final control to the Lord is extremely difficult
and our human nature just simply rebels against it. And that's why you know I really appreciate her
still struggling with this in volume 17 because then I say to myself don't be so hard on yourself
someone much better than you had difficulty don't you want to trust your Jesus he said
let me do let me do we find it very difficult to let God actually take over oh yeah we'll say the
words and we'll say beautiful prayers to him and in the beautiful prayers we'll promise it the
soul moon and stars but in the actual handing over of something that's different so he said and do not
take things lightly he said rather he said how many sad things are about to happen he still needs
this sacrifice from her my justice he said can no longer hold back the lightnings to strike human
beings all the justice and light things are about to break out one against the other and when you
hear of the evils of your brothers that means humanity you will feel remorse about your oppositions
to your usual sacrifice now see that there now your usual sacrifice which is this is your daily
sacrifice your morning or evening sacrifice to God you've got to let this priest come and do this
office for you you've been doing fine why are you going into a tizzy now but that's what we're like
as human beings and I love these writings being so honest so he said you'd feel remorse about your
oppositions to your usual sacrifice as if you had put your hand in pushing justice to strike the
creatures in other words he's saying to her try and keep keep in mind the fact that you're in this
very special position vis-a-vis the divine will and humanity and all the sacrifices that you are
called upon to make are all very important now for you and me who aren't luisa and are not called to
her great mission to open the divine will to the world we can make the mistake of thinking
that a little sacrifice asked of us may not be all that important and we might just let it go
you know that if you are knitting a jumper or a cardigan every single stitch is vital
and if you drop a stitch and try to finish the cardigan it's an imperfect thing it would never
sell if you try to sell it nobody else would want it they will see the drop stitch they will see the
bit you actually left out and so we're inclined to not think it's so important to make the various
sacrifices that are asked of us okay and the thing that I would like to add to this is that
when the church is in crisis as it is now we the laity are attempted to go ahead without the
church and this is going to be something that will be very topical as soon as we are allowed to
leave our homes and go back to church for services you'll find that people got used to having mass
on the the screen and they may not want the bother of actually joining a congregation in a church
they've got used to sort of being outside the body that's one of the problems we're going to have
very soon some laypeople who get into the divine will spirituality think that because we have
all these privileges in the divine will that we don't need the church and we don't need the mass
and we don't need the sacrament it's a huge problem massive problem Jesus says no you do need them
and you do need the church and whatever you think is wrong with the church or the hierarchy or anybody
else creased and that's your your offering to the Lord you may have a thorn in your side about it
but that's your offering to the Lord the church in its everyday appearance it comes across to us
as quite imperfect that's fine aren't we imperfect as well so we have to be careful that we don't
want to be excused from our normal duties and excused from the normal sacrifices that are asked
i just wanted to give you that little bit of off the page and so that we would adapt it a little bit
to us so on hearing this louisa said my Jesus may it never be nor do i want to withdraw from your will
on the contrary i pray you to free me from the most awful of misfortunes and that is of going
outside of your holy will the the problem occasioned her to actually make a statement that is very
important for us that the worst of all tragedies for us is to go outside of the divine will nor do i
ask you to free me from suffering brother you can increase it if you want only i pray you and as a
grace i want from you only if you wanted that you free me from the bother i have with the confessor
poor soul i want to give you two Corinthians 12 seven all had a thorny's side as well and he said
that he asked the lord three times in the scriptures three is is a very big thing to remove this poor
louisa has asked him on on teen times she said it's too hard for me the confessor coming and i feel i
do not have the strength to bear it so only if you please otherwise you said give me the strength
but do not permit that that your most holy will would not be fulfilled in may so she has now
clarified the issues jesus doesn't doesn't need the clarification she herself needs it and when
we're working through something it's we ourselves need the clarification not the lord and that is
she wants to do god's will but she really would like that it would be his will to do this she
knows darn well it isn't his will so then she slips in a little bit i need more strength
and that's what we need to do is say to the lord if you're asking this of me you've got to fortify me
you've got to give me the gift of fortitude and so jesus resumes speaking and he said my daughter
and he reminds her of the day that she made her her formal consecration to him now i know we have
an act of consecration to the divine will and it's beautiful and you can see it as often as you like
but there actually comes a moment in your life and it may not be when you're saying that prayer
it may not be when you're in church you could be in bed just before going asleep
or just upon waking or it could be you're just out walking
when inside of you there comes this moment i call it the clinching moment when you say okay lord it's
now i surrender give it to you i'll never take it back i surrender it then your act of consecration
to the divine will takes on a value and a depth that is absolutely fantastic so he brings her back
to that moment when she gave her fiat he said my daughter remember that i asked you for a fiat
in my will do you have the reference for that if you don't then you'll find it in
february the 10th 1919 and it's volume 12 when she gave her official fiat she had been in the divine
will for quite some a number of years before that but this is was the the final moment of surrender
and so extremely important for the lord and not only that but she said that she wanted
to make this fiat in the divine will so that the very act of surrendering herself to the lord
would be a divine will act that it wouldn't just be louisa saying yes it was louisa in the divine will
that was saying yes now that made her commitment to the lord extremely sacred so he says my daughter
remember when i asked you for a yes or a fiat in my will and you pronounced it with all love
that yes or that fiat still exists and it holds its first place in my on ending will now why does
it hold first place it's because louisa is the first person who was born with original sin
who reached this point of making this commitment to the lord you see you can't include our blessed
mother because she was born without original sin you can't include adam he was born without
original sin you can't include jesus he was born without original sin excuse me for even saying
those words with regard to jesus i'm just trying to make a point and so so louisa is the first one
from a fallen human race who came back and made this fiat in a very solemn way to the lord
jesus said your yes or your fiat holds its first place in my on ending will everything you do
think and say is bound to that fiat now notice everything all your thoughts all your words all
your actions all your motivations all your desires absolutely everything is in that fiat everything's
in it so that means that everything is on the level of the divine will breathing is on the level of
the divine will it's fantastic and from this fiat nothing can escape and my will enjoys and makes
feast in seeing a will of a creature live in my will and it offers a little a very important
she's the first century later there are others okay but she's the first one so she's a will of a
creature so it must have been great joy in heaven when the first of the fallen and redeemed human race
came back with the fiat he said and i keep filling it that's the fiat with new graces and i constitute
all your acts as divine acts now notice who's doing what jesus said i am the one that constitutes
your acts divine acts he's the only one who can because he's the divine one so all we can do is
put our acts into the divine will and allow him to do this transformation this is the greatest
portent that exists between heaven and earth it is the object dearest to me and if may it never be
it was torn away from me i would feel myself being torn and would cry bitterly now why does he say
i would feel myself being torn it's because louisa and jesus are now one they are now inseparable
and there's only one will between them and that one will is the divinity and the divinity is
operating in her so if she pulls away from that she's actually doing something unbelievably
ferocious we can hardly take this on board i would feel myself being torn and i would cry
bitterly see as you are making that little opposition that is i get disturbed and i start
asking you can i get out of this okay and i'm trying to ask you could you possibly make it your will
cause us my will and i know we have to give up that as you are making your little opposition
she's he said your fiat trembled with fright at that trembling the foundations of the heavens
were shaken and were trembling why because there's a divine will involved and the divine will keeps
everything together and the divine will keeps heaven together and keeps the whole of the universe
together and so she had the ability to offend in a divine way that part of it is a bit frightening
all the saints and all the angels and the whole sphere of eternity looked with horror and sorrow
as they felt an act of divine will being torn away from them because you know that an act in
the divine will affect everybody in heaven and everybody in purgatory everybody on earth
and the whole of creation everything and everyone because since my will envelops everyone
and everything they felt the act you had done as one thing with themselves because they're all
in the divine will the whole of creation is in the divine will it was not given the freedom to come
out of it all the angels that are in heaven are in the divine will all the saints are in the divine
will so they're all affected by this decision so they felt the acts that you had done as one thing
with themselves and therefore they all felt this painful tearing that's very interesting
so we need to see the enormity of the commitment that we actually make in the divine will and the
effect it will have in heaven purgatory and earth and in the whole universe if we pull back
I would say Jesus said that all took the attitude of profound sorrow
I think that's an extremely important section where it's explained to us in great detail the enormity
of what happens if we move away from the divine will
so everything in heaven in purgatory in the universe is all in harmony with the divine will
wear the words out of harmony so if we come into that harmony it is something huge
so louisa was frightened at this message of Jesus and she said my love what are you saying
is this possible all this evil your words make me die of pain or please forgive me she said
have mercy on me I'm so bad and I confirm my yes with stronger bonds in your will
now notice that this is not the first time this has happened that she had a struggle
and when she realizes the enormity of what is involved she then plunges herself much more deeply
into the divine will and that's the way to deal with it now you say no no no I surrender
completely absolutely into your divine will in fact I want to go deeper into it
and once he knows you want to go there then he accepts the struggle you're having now
as just a momentary thing if I can put it this way you're only having a cold you're not dying
even more she said make me die rather than letting me go out with the divine will
so she has now reached something very important she has reached a point she hadn't reached before
and that is let me die rather than go out with the divine will now if you if you go back to volumes
one to four she had reached the point of let me die rather than sin now this is much much greater
much deeper much more all inclusive of of the whole of reality and she said let me die rather
than go out of your will so notice that the Lord's wisdom and enables him well Greg would say to
maneuver it in such a way that you come around to to making up for the mistake you've made
and Jesus said my daughter cam yourself as soon as you have placed yourself in my will again
we have known this since volume one that if you slip out of the divine will as soon as
possible go back in as soon as you place yourself in my will again all things that is the entire
creation heaven and purgatory and earth have calmed themselves and have taken the attitude
of a new feast your fiat continues its rapid rounds in the immensity of my will
add over neither you nor those who direct you that the priests that are supposed to be guiding her
my book says have known what he's really saying is have understood what it means to live in my
will so he says neither you nor the priests who are directing you have understood what it means to
live in my will this is why you don't appreciate it and it's held as something of no importance
this is a sorrow for me while this is the thing that interests me the most and which more than
all things should interest everybody so the priests are still not taking this
as seriously as they should and they're not really understanding i have sympathy for them because
louisa it's completely new to her as well in the sense that it's a completely new way of relating
to god and she doesn't really have the ability to explain it and all she can do is go back to
jesus for another message and gives them another message which she herself can't argue this out
with them or defend her position and jesus wants everybody of course understanding the divine will
and moving into it but alas he said they that's the priests pay attention to other things
and to things that are less pleasing or even indifferent to me rather than that which glorifies
me the most and which gives them also on this earth immense and eternal goods and renders them
owners of the goods which my will possesses so if you're not into the divine will you're in the
ordinary i'm talking about somebody good now so i'm i'm talking about the priests guiding louisa
so if they're not in the divine will they're in the ordinary spirituality and so they're more
interested in things less than what the lord is revealing and if they're a bit worldly as well
they're interested in stuff that he he's not interested in at all and they're missing out the
enormity of the gifts and the graces that he actually wants to give them
see he said my will is one is one unit and it embraces all eternity we know from other volumes
that we've read up to now that when he says my will is one you're talking about singularity it is
one point and past present and future are all in that point everything's in that point all of creation
is in that point everything is in it and so it embraces the whole of eternity now by living in my
will and by making it her own now notice the living that's 24 7 3 6 5 by living in my will and by making
it her own the soul comes to take part in all the joys and the goods that my will contains this is
absolutely amazing so if we're to take part in all the joys and all the goods we can take part in
creation and redemption and sanctification and absolutely everything I mean look at the size of us
we're absolute nothings and yet the one who is everything allows us to put our drop of water
in the wine of his love the soul comes to take part in all the joys and the goods that my will
contains and she becomes as though the owner of them were allowed to participate it's absolutely
amazing if we ever get it on board that living in the divine will and living fused in the divine
will gives you the possession of God and puts you in a position where you can do things with the
divine will you suddenly realize the power you have to change things on the earth and even though
while being on earth she does not feel all these joys and goods by keeping them in deposit within
her will by virtue of my will done on earth when she dies she finds herself up there in heaven
and she will feel all these joys and goods which my will issued in heaven while she was living on
earth okay now one of the problems that you can have the living in the divine will is you don't
feel any different and you can make all these wonderful acts in the divine will and I don't know
whoever said to yourself are these just words you know or are they realities you don't feel it
but you you feel the trials and you'll feel the sufferings and you'll feel the sacrifices because
on the earth we suffer and he's going to explain that in a minute but he says that the the feeling
as in you enjoy something is for heaven the work the mission the sacrifice the pain the paying the
price is for the earth just as in Jesus own life himself but he says that everything is held for
you in heaven nothing will be taken away from her he says on the contrary it will be multiplied in
fact if the saints have enjoyed my will in heaven because they live in the divine will however it's
always enjoying that they have now they're in heaven their mission is over nothing else is asked
of them so they're in the position of actually enjoying all the happiness and joy of the divine
will because that's the position of heaven while the soul who lives in my will on the earth lives
suffering so enjoyment for heaven suffering for earth so on the earth we have to work and suffer
in the divine will just as Jesus and Mary did we have a job to do and we have a mission to accomplish
and sacrifices to make and so the cross is for the earth the crown is for heaven is it not right
that she take those joys and those goods which others have taken in heaven while she is living on
the earth in that same will in which they lived so he keeps on telling Louisa that the divine will
is the source of all happiness and source of all joy how would we measure the happiness and the joy
that the divine will actually gives us on the earth i think you measure it with Philippians 4
7 the peace that passes all understanding and guards your heart and your mind in Christ Jesus
as that peace goes deeper and deeper and becomes more solid and nobody can shift it then you know
that you've gone deeper and deeper and deeper to me as far as i know that is the the sign
but you will never be without the suffering and the cross while you're on the earth
how many immense riches one who lives in my will on earth does not take so we get all these gifts
and graces and joys and everything but he says they're kept in a bank for us and we do the enjoyment
part of it in heaven i can say he said that the whole of eternity moves around this soul to enrich
her and to make her happy my will deprives her of nothing of what it contains she is its daughter
and it loves her so much that it does not want to deprive her of anything therefore be attentive
my daughter and do not want to oppose my designs which i have made upon you what is our happiness
on the earth now i said how do you register it and i gave you peace as a sign for registering it
i want to give you a couple of references i want to give you john 434 where jesus said my food
or my satisfaction or my joy is to do the will of the one who sent me and to finish his work
my joy my food what actually gives me satisfaction is doing the will of the one who sent me
and finishing the work that he gave me to do and then the sign as i said is the peace that passes
all understanding now that's a wonderful piece and lovely and rich and so here's the one about
living in the divine will and if you ever want to give a talk on the divine will you have the whole
out of it here it's really wonderful this is september 17th 1924 louisa said i was thinking
about the holy divine will and i was doing as much as i could in order to fuse myself in it
look at that expression i was doing as much as i could we don't all succeed all the time
you can say the words but actually getting into the divine will might cost you a little bit
so i was doing as much as i could she said in order to fuse myself with the divine will
to be able to embrace everyone that means we bring all humanity back to god which is our
mission and to bring to my god as one single act the act of everyone which are all due to the creator
now while i was doing this she said i saw heaven open and a sun capital s which is the divine will
came out of it which my book says wounding me but it's not using the word as we use it
to us a wound is a problem okay so touching me i would say deeply with its rays penetrated
deep into the depths of my soul now when i'm finished this i would suggest that if you're
able to draw that you draw this and it can give you enormous enlightenment
so you have the sun up here and the rays coming down to penetrate luisa's soul and then you're
going to have her responding by sending the rays back her responses back into the divine will and
then he starts transforming them and watch what happens so a sun came out of it it's coming from
heaven and touching me deeply with its rays it penetrated deep into the depths of my soul
which again she says wounded touched by those rays converted into a sun small s okay the first one
is him the second one is the soul which spreading its rays wounded that sun or touched the sun now
this is the response going back to the source from which it had been touched itself and since i
continued doing my acts for everyone in the divine will these acts were overwhelmed by these rays
in other words god is the one who does the transformation transformation so these acts were
overwhelmed by these rays and converted into divine acts so only god can do it because only a divine
person can do something divine and so we give him our response to what he has given to us and he
transforms it which diffusing within all and overall formed a net of light now look at the
solution that we're being told to planet earth which has a pole of darkness over it and we're being
told how we can put a net of light to dispel that darkness i think it's brilliant it formed a net
of light such as to put order between the creator and the creature now the whole job that has to be
done in the divine will is to re-establish the divine order the divine order in us individually
among us as groups in society and in the whole of humanity and therefore reorder the whole of creation
and that's your roman's eight text from verse 19 that the whole of creation is crying out for this
to happen and so luisa said i remain enchanted in seeing this and my beloved jesus coming out from
within my interior which means the kingdom of god is within her that's luke 17 21
and one karinthians 3 16 so he came out from within my interior in the middle of this sun now
this sun with the capital s is the divine will and he told me my daughter see how beautiful is the
sun of my will what power and what marvel as soon as the soul wants to fuse herself you desire it
i do it do you remember as soon as the soul wants to fuse herself in the divine will in order to
embrace everybody and everything my will turning into a sun and this time i said the word wounds i'm
going to use the word penetrates which actually fits the context better penetrates the soul because
she said it went deeply into her soul it penetrates the soul and forms another sun now my book has a
capital s there i don't know about yours but it should be a small one because it's creating the
little sun in us and as she performs her acts in the divine will the soul forms its rays in order
to penetrate the sun of the supreme will now the sun has a big capital s and overwhelming everything
and everyone into this light she loves she glorifies she satisfies her creator for everyone and everything
that is the most divine explanation of an act i think it's absolutely brilliant and what is more
she does it not with human love glory and satisfaction but with the love and glory of the divine will
because the sun capital s of my will has operated or acted within her
do you see then what it means to do acts in my will this is the living in my will
the sun of my will transforming the human will into a sun small s this time do you have the problem
of the big and the small s so the sun of the divine will transforms the human will into a small sun
acts within it as in its own center because it's the divine will operating in the soul
so the next paragraph is about the the writings then afterwards my sweet Jesus went on taking
all the books but written on his divine will he united them together and he pressed them to his
heart and with unspeakable tenderness he added i blessed these writings from the heart i blessed
each word i blessed the effects and the value that they contain these writings are part of myself
it's not fantastic but we know that when we're reading it there's this there's enormous grace
in just reading this text even if you didn't understand it there's enormous grace in reading it
these writings are part of myself he said and then he called the angels who prostrated themselves
with their faces to the ground he called them to pray and since the two priests were there present
who were supposed to see the writings jesus told the angels to touch the priests
foreheads in order to impress on them the holy spirit look at the angels as the servants of god
here and i want to give you um Hebrews uh one and i think it's 13 to 14 that the the work that god
is given to the angels with regard to us is to help us on our way to salvation
and also if you go to the book of jennises and the story of um Abraham at the oak of memory
you have the task of the angels to try and help Abraham to intercede for the people who are
going to be judged in sardom and kumara so the angels here were told to touch the forehead of
the priests in order to impress on them the holy spirit so as to infuse in them the light
we would say enlightenment in order to make them understand the truths and the goods
which are in these writings now you notice that that is brought into our prayer before study
that we actually need enlightenment uh to understand the writings and to understand the
enormous gifts and graces that are offered to us so the angels executed that and jesus blessing us
all disappeared so in order to really understand these writings we need knowledge with understanding
knowledge without understanding is actually quite useless but knowledge with understanding
enables you to grow and that's what god wants to give to us now do you want me to go on do the next one
yes it's up to you amelza yes yes french's people are saying yes okay i just need their
their agreement because um this is our first time to do it i just want to to see uh what
what's um length of patience you have when everybody is still with us okay that's grand
everybody said yes no september the 18th is the one where you get your complete talk on how to
live in the divine will i mean all the points are there and what i've done this afternoon
when i was preparing this uh was that i took a sheet of paper and started writing it down
one thing after another and there's an entire teaching that you can give to a group here
absolutely marvelous so this is this is seminar material uh september the 18th
where the lord explains the difference between living in the divine will and living with your own
will uh louisa said i was worried about uh what has been written on the living in the divine will
and i was praying jesus to give me more light in order to explain myself better so that i might
be able to clarify more this blessed living in the divine will to those to whom i'm all
obliged to do so that's to the priests and jesus told me my daughter they don't want to understand
so that means that jesus thinks that it's not that difficult to live in my will this is the
first point he makes is to reign so if you're going to make your list living in the divine will
and living in your own will you can have them as two columns whichever way you want to do it
to do my will is to be submitted to my orders just as we have seen the angels there
submitted to jesus orders he ordered them to touch the priests on their foreheads and infuse
the holy spirit and they did it so that's receiving orders um to live in the divine will
means to possess and you should really add another word it is to possess god and to possess god
is the greatest privilege in heaven and on earth
to do god's will is simply to receive orders and execute them which is the position of the vast
majority of good christians so now we come to the next point to live in the divine will
is to make the divine will your own as your own thing and to dispose of it now i don't think you
can get a statement bigger than that letter to live in the divine will is to make the divine will
our own and it's to make it's our own thing it's my own possession the pen in my hand is mine i can
dispose of it he says you can dispose of it i just find that absolutely mind-boggling
it's only when you take it on board that you realize what you're saying
but to do my will which is the other side is to simply hold it as the will of god
not as your own thing nor can you dispose of it because it's not yours
so notice living in the divine will is possession of god living the other spirituality or living
in your own will is completely different and this clarifies it very very much here's the next point
to live in my will is to live with one single will that of god
now before we even finish that sentence i've to stop
you know that the three divine persons have one will and that one will means that there is
stability that there is harmony there is immutability and all the attributes of god are absolutely
multiplied to infinity and eternity for eternal what jesus is talking about here is that same
will that governs the blessed trinity comes into our possession that's what he's talking about
so the same will that's governing the blessed trinity in heaven is governing me
that i have the same relationship i just think it's unbelievable that this is a trinity and
spirituality so to live in my will is to live with one single will that of god and since it is a will
all holy pure full of peace and it is one single will that reigns you see if god is in me and there's
two wills there's trouble if there are three divine persons and three wills there is trouble
there's one will in the three divine persons and when the lord allows me to take possession of him
then there is one will and it's not mine it's his will that's governing that's why he says to live
in the divine will is to reign so he says it is the one single will that reigns so there are no
contrasts that means there's no battles everything is peace so that's your Philippians 4 7 again
everything is peace human passions tremble before the supreme will and they would want to shun it
nor do they dare to even move or to oppose it seeing that heaven and earth tremble before the
divine will now what he's saying here is that when we come to the place where we have the true
possession of god the passions and the desires and motivations and everything we have everything
will be subdued under the divine will everything at the a lower spirituality when two wills are
operating and you're trying to struggle to do the divine will you're struggling also with your
passions and your desires and your distant the other the first step in living in the divine will
what does it do it lays the divine order in the depth of the soul so here again we have a huge
text giving us discernment as to where we're at because if god comes to live in my soul he has to
put everything in divine order look at the first two sentences of the bible it says in the beginning
god created the heavens and the earth and the second sentence said there was chaos and the third
sentence says and god started putting everything in divine order and the rest of the chapter one
of genesis is god putting everything into order so when we come into relationship with the divine
will that's what the lord wants from the beginning is that everything will go back into the divine
order and if things in me are not actually going back into the divine order then i am not in the
place that i boast about i'm not in the place where i say i am what's the first thing that the
divine will does it lays the divine order in the depth of the soul it empties her of what is human
now what precisely has to be emptied human tendencies that's very interesting
human passions human inclinations and the like i'd love to know what the like is
because the tendencies passions and inclinations keep you going wouldn't it on the other hand he
says to do my will is to live with two wills you see this is very very clear it's it's very hard
to mistake this to do my will is to live with two wills and when i give orders to do mine
one feels the weight of one's own will and which causes contrasts and even if one follows the orders
of my will with faithfulness one feels the weight of one's rebellious nature and of one's passions
and inclinations so i want to give you luke 1613 i want to give you luke 1247
and matthew 21 28 to 32 now anyway if you've ever done any baby sitting
i did it for a very short time and i gave it up because a mother walking out the door would say
don't touch the biscuits there's only one issue for the rest of the night biscuits if the mother had
said nothing you probably enjoyed the darn thing it's because as soon as an order is given to a
human being the rebellion is touched and when that rebellion is touched then the struggle happens
i remember having a little fellow saying to me at 11 o'clock at night my mother always gives me
coffee at 11 o'clock at night i said we'll be glad your mother isn't here these are the contrasts
between two wills and if we're in this struggle between the two wills we still have a journey
yet to go to get into the fullness of the possession of the divine will that's why i say that this
passage is terrific for discernment how many saints jesus said though they may have reached
the highest perfection feel their own will waiting war against them keeping them oppressed
and many are forced to cry out who will free me from this body of death that's
Saint Paul Romans 7 21 to 25 and also one Corinthians 9 27
he's giving an example of Saint Paul here and he prefaces by saying that they reach the highest
perfection but because they didn't have the divine will as we have they had the the full battle
of the the body against the soul so who will free me from this body of death that is from this will
of mine which wants to give death to the good that i want to do now the next point is to live in my
will is to live as a son in his father's house the scriptures have a lot on that so i'm not going
to give you any reference really because if you just take john's gospel jesus says that he is the
son and and shows you the privileges that he has if you just take john 5 19 and the rest of that
chapter you'll get everything that i want to say there the son will do what the father does and
the father reveals everything to the son and so on and that's what he's saying here as well to live
in my will is to live as a son to do my will is to live as a servant in the house now that's a very
very different relationship in the first state what belongs to the father belongs to the son
so when we enter into the divine will the divine will is mine and i am his and you find that the
song of song is my beloved is mine and i am his i really belong to him and many times he said servants
make more sacrifices than the sons do they have to expose themselves to more toilsome and humble
services to the cold the heat and traveling on foot in fact how much have my saints not done
in order to execute the orders of my will okay i want to give you Hebrews three verses five and six
where the author compares Moses as the servant and Jesus as the son on the other hand he said
a son remains with his father takes care of him cheers in with these kisses and with these caresses
he commands the servants as if his father were commanding i have john 8 35 there
if he goes out he does not go out on 40 travels in a carriage and while the son possesses everything
that belongs to the father servants are given only the retribution for the work that they have done
and they remain free to serve or not to serve the master and if they don't serve
they've no more right to receive any further compensation i want to give you two Corinthians
two 15 to 16 where Saint Paul raises that image to the spiritual level and he says that the
the unspiritual just don't get us in terms of understanding God's ways but the spiritual the
truly spiritual people can judge everything and they cannot be judged by the world who the son
possesses everything and once the servant is paid for his work well that's it there's no more
obligation and you have that in the parable of the servants who are paid you know at the 11th
hour and the ones at the first hour complain so i want to give you Matthew 25 23 and Luke 12 47
so on the other hand between the father and the son no one can remove these rights
the son possesses the goods of the father no law either celestial or terrestrial can remove
these rights no law celestial or terrestrial can unbind the sonship between the father and the son
so john 10 30 the father and i are one my daughter he said living in my will is living that is the
closest to the blessed in heaven you see we're living with the same will as them we're living in the
same surrender as them it's just that they're living in celebration and we're living in suffering
and it is so distant from one who does my will and is faithfully submitted to my orders
and the distance is the distance between heaven and earth it's just as we would say it's a different
world just as the distance between a son and a servant or between a king and a subject and besides
this is a gift which i want to give in these times so sad now there you have
that when sin abounds graced or even more abound
that they may not only do my will but actually possess it so i want to give you Romans 9 15 there
am i perhaps not free to give whatever i want whenever i want and whomever i want god is god
he's the creator he can do what he likes and yet we're inclined to say it's not fair
is a master not free to say to his servant live in my house eat take command take command like
another me now this living in the father's house is is quite important so i'll just read the next
little bit and then say something it's the master not free to say to his servant live in my house
eat take command like another me so that no one may prevent him from possessing his goods
he legitimizes his servant as his own son we would say adopts this servant as his own son
and gives him the right to possess if a rich man can do this how much more can i do it
now the big example of that well there's two examples i could give you out of a number but the
big one i would want to give you is joseph in egypt when he went to live in the house of potty far
that's genesis 39 verses 1 to 6 and he was only a slave and in no time at all he was running the
whole business for his master and even when he was put in jail in no time at all he was running
the whole thing and then the third one is genesis 41 37 verses 37 to 45 that pharaoh actually puts
joseph next to himself running egypt he was the pharaoh he could do it he had the right to do it
then if you take somebody like go down centuries and you get someone like ester
and she's taken into the house of ashwaris and she's only a second wife and there's a pharaoh
anyway and yet the extraordinary thing is in no time at all she's in charge and she's rolling
it's quite an amazing thing so the lord does that as well
and i mean even if you take the the choice of the slaves in egypt and the lord adopting them
and setting them free and setting them up as a people of god i mean it was all his work
so this living in my will is the greatest gift i want to give to creatures jesus said
my goodness wants to make an even greater display of love towards creatures
so the lord made a huge display of love in creating us in redeeming us and now he says
i want to give the greatest gift of all but he couldn't give it until after he had redeemed us
and since i have given them everything that's jesus saying that in his humanity he has already
given everything i've nothing else to give to make myself loved i want to give them the gift of my
will so he has given everything already in his humanity now he gives everything he is in his divinity
that should make us do enormous meditation on who god is look at his self-giving look at his
humility look at the outpouring of everything he is to give life and grace and love and the attitude
and everything to everybody else it's amazing so since i have nothing else to give in my humanity
understood i want to give them the gift of my will so that by possessing my will they may love
the great good that they possess and don't be surprised if they don't understand now the day
is the priests that's that's the immediate context for louisa but we can put that onto a larger platform
and say the majority are not going to understand even a very good christians because he has told
us time and again that only very few will accept the divine will why because of the sacrifice of
surrendering yourself the sacrifice of giving up your will most people wouldn't even consider it
and so jesus says in order to understand they would have to dispose themselves to the greatest
sacrifices that of not giving life even in holy things to their own will and that's what even
people with with very high jobs in the church mightn't be prepared to do it's really sad
and it's our own decision we're not prepared to make this sacrifice so then you will get the
the benefits that go with it so don't be surprised that they don't understand in order to understand
they have to dispose themselves to the greatest of sacrifices that of not giving life even in holy
things to their own will now i love the way he emphasizes in holy things because there are many
christians who think that the very fact of going to a physical church and kneeling or sitting or
standing in a physical church and saying yes or no or whatever they should say to the liturgy that's
there is a holy thing and they may not actually surrender their heart or their will to god they
may be doing their own thing i remember with horror at the end of a funeral service in this parish
they sang i did it my way i actually walked out in total horror they had no idea what they were
saying and they were saying that this was the way this person who was going to be buried had lived
i did it my way so they're not prepared even in holy things to give up their own will then
if they did give up their own will they would feel the possession of mine because have you noticed
that if we surrender even their emotions little bit he moves in and he takes that little bit we give
them the ground side by side you know they would feel the possession of mine and they would touch
with their own hands what it means to live in my will you however should be attentive and do not
be bothered by the difficulties that the priests raise and i little by little will make my way
to make them understand the living in my will so what jesus saying here is that living in the divine
will only come slowly now for you and me who have been reflecting on these writings for a number of
years i think we would acknowledge that that is actually true it only comes slowly we only get
it sip by sip so i want to stop there for tonight and i hope you find this helpful
okay and let's just finish by asking the lord to bless us all lord jesus we put all our thoughts
and our words into your thoughts and your words we fuse ourselves completely in you all of us
in all of you all the time so that you can glorify yourself in us and through us all the time
and we ask this through Jesus Christ our Lord. Amen.